bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de municipales 2014 sur tv fils
je recevrai dans un instant jean luc
trotignon candidat du centre gauche
écologistes à rambouillet c'est un
ancien responsable de l'association
contre la corruption en politique
anticor il siège depuis 2008 dans
l'opposition face à gérard larcher
nicolas bauer candidat du rassemblement
bleu marine à elancourt viendra aussi
s'exprimer sur cette émission suppléant
aux dernières les élections législatives
sur la 11e circonscription il est
maintenant candidat tête de liste aux
municipales nous évoquons aussi le
rapprochement entre le modem et le ps à
plaisir est les visites attrapé à magny
les hameaux de benoist apparu ancien
ministre du logement venu soutenir les
jeunes candidats de l'ump qui se
présente aux élections et puis la
campagne qui débute pour gaitan
desjardins saint cyr l'école elle a
quitté son poste d'adjointe au maire et
se présentera donc contre lui
le premier invité ce soir c'est donc le
jean luc trotignon bonsoir qui nous soit
venu sur ce plateau représentant de la
liste rambouillet renouveau une liste de
centre gauche écologique soutenue par le
parti socialiste et seulement cinq ans
car tu es sûr sur votre liste oui
absolument une liste très
majoritairement citoyenne puisque sur 35
personnes effectivement il y en a trente
qui sont des citoyens qui vient de mon
associatifs citoyens
syndicale ce que ce qu'on veut mais non
pas des partis politiques mais vous qui
avait adhéré au parti socialiste assez
récemment finalement il ya peu près un
an et demi oui c'est ça pourquoi ne pas
mettre en avant cette appartenance
socialiste parce que c'est pas dans la
tendance du moment aussi non c'est pas
bon d'abord mon investissement principal
c'est celui que j'ai eu à anticor depuis
plusieurs années où j'étais délégué
national vice-président et sociales sont
je rappelle qu'il luttait qui lutte
contre la corruption en politique tout à
fait et pour la transparence également
et
donc c'est beaucoup là dessus que des
personnes ont souhaité me rejoindre
puisque j'ai agi en fonction de cela
pendant mon mandat et donc voilà il ya
une autre liste a effectivement des gens
de sensibilité de gauche des gens de
sensibilité écologiste et des gens de
sensibilité du centre également la
surprise de ces derniers mois c'est le
départ annoncé de gérard larcher pas de
nouvelles candidatures pour celui qui
détient pour l'ump cette ville depuis
plus de 30 ans quelle réaction à cette
décision de gérard larcher puis est ce
que ça peut changer la donne aussi sur
ce scrutin alors je trouve que c'est une
réaction intelligente au niveau
anticipation par rapport à la loi sur le
cumul des mandats puisque en 2017 qui
leur est dû choisir donc il s et les
électeurs rambolitains tranché ce qui
est plus sain pour la démocratie
effectivement et ce qui fait qu'il n'y
aura pas de prime au sortant et on le
sent déjà en début de campagne optmiste
campagne les les électeurs pour eux le
surplus ouverte ils vont choisir entre
deux principaux candidats puissent y
aura aussi d'autres listes pour la
succession et ils vont voir ça en
étudiant les programmes d'un peu plus
près que d'habitude gérard larcher qui a
quasiment à chaque fois été élu au
premier tour durant ses différentes
candidatures 2008 lors de votre
candidature première candidature 30%
environ des suffrages a trouvé un pour
cent on m'avait bourrières inverser
cette tendance aussi radicalement 57%
pour gérard larcher en 2008 parce que il
y avait une prime gérard larcher si vous
voulez parce que il ya les villes les
électeurs avec leurs mères sont souvent
assez conservateur
jeu l'élection avant celle où je me suis
présenté il était passé au premier tour
à 71 pour tous en nous on a réussi à le
faire baisser à 57% nous allons finir le
travail en mars prochain il y avait une
autre liste de gauche qui s'était
présenté en 2008 tout à fait est que
vous avez échangé avec elle ses
candidats ce qui aura une rassemblé
seulement c'était une liste qui s'était
présenté en disant qu'il n'y avait pas
besoin des partis politiques pour gérer
une ville donc uniquement aux citoyennes
et maintenant ces élus sont plutôt
passer de vous coûter du front de gauche
donc ils souhaitent monter leur liste de
façon indépendante aura pas d'alliance
en tout cas au premier tour le front de
gauche et europe écologie 6 il arrive à
monter leurs listes dans ce cas il ne
souhaite pas pour l'instant ni europe
écologie a priori c'est parti comme ça
mais de look ou encore coulé sous les
ponts avant l'élection on vous connaît
surtout comme ancien vice président de
cette association anticor responsable si
dans le département des yvelines pour
anticor association anti corruption
transparence en politique passée de
l'autre côté vous engagez prendre votre
carte dans un parti aussi au parti
socialiste c'était une démarche
longtemps réfléchi ou c'est un
engagement change en fait c'est naturel
c'est plutôt l'inversé c'est à dire que
j'ai démarré en étant élu enfin j'ai
cinq enfants gilles médaillés de la
famille disons plus j'ai eu d'enfant
plus j'ai eu envie de mettre fera la
main à la pâte de la société dans
laquelle ils vont devenir adulte et ça
m'a amené d'investissement en
investissement à des fonctions électives
et à ce moment-là à rambouillet j'ai
exercé mon droit de contrôle sur la
gestion de la municipalité et je suis
tombé sur des des affaires comme les ai
découverts des élus toucher des
indemnités de façon illicite
puis j'ai découvert qu'il s'était il
s'agissait même de monsieur larcher qui
touchaient des indemnités en trop perçus
en 2008 qu'il a fini par rembourser en
deux temps
et à ce moment là je me suis dit que
c'est quand même le numéro de l'état
faut peut-être que j'aille voir une
association de type anticorps pour me
mais paul est un petit peu voilà et
c'est ainsi que j'ai été élu d'abord et
puis j'ai rejoint anticorps et là le le
mariage avec anticorps pour moi s'est
fait très rapidement puisqu'un an plus
tard j'étais vice-président de
l'association puis délégué national
enfin et c'est pour tous les bus vous
étiez plutôt du côté du pôle républicain
nous on perd ce vêtement ça c'est tout à
fait pourquoi cet engagement en quelques
mots pourquoi sam allemand parce que
j'appréciais le personnage mais disons
que le parti lui même m'a déçu
à force donc je me suis principalement
investi pendant ce mandat effectivement
avec anticorps anti corps qui a édictée
une charte pour 2014 pour ces
municipales sur qui engage ensuite les
candidats un non-cumul la transparence
prévention du trafic d'influencé a fait
partie des quelques points qui sont
édités dans cette charte d'anticorps
vous l'avait signé j'ai pas encore signé
seul à signer dans les mois qui viennent
très vraisemblablement mai son
désengagement pour tout le mandat si
nous sommes élus majoritaires donc je
souhaite que ma liste définitivement
constitué pour leur en parler en
débattre avec eux et pas leur imposer
dans une sorte de premier habite pouvoir
mais j'en aurai pas d'autres non plus
d'ailleurs derrière ceci dit ce serait
la moindre des choses en tant que
responsable d'anticorps c'est un
responsable ne pas signer cette charte
d'engagement se contentant d'une
participation des cultures également
donc voilà domaniale assigne également à
l'achat dé l'association nationale des
élus locaux d'opposition dont je suis
administrateur qui est aussi une
association qui regroupe des élus de
droite et de gauche tout comme anticorps
mais peut-être ça rejoint effectivement
le pôle républicain au départ de jean
pierre chevènement s'ouvrait un petit
peu de ses côtés des deux côtés votre
liste pour les municipales qui est
quasiment bouclé le manque encore
quelques candidats pour attendre les 35
nécessaire pour rambouillet quels sont
les points de programme là aussi c'est
en cours d'élaboration de finition à
leurs axes principaux c'est en cours
d'élaboration seulement à rambouillet
les gens en ont assez de voter pour des
gens qui leur font des promesses pour la
majorité municipale tous les six ans et
puis de ne plus avoir de contrôle
derrière de contrôle sur le travail de
leurs élus et de se retrouver avec une
eau qui est à l'heure actuelle 63 % plus
cher que la moyenne nationale avec une
taxe ordures ménagères qui dans les 40 %
plus cher que la moyenne nationale avec
8 millions d'euros de pénalités à
rembourser pour les autres sorties
d'emprunts toxiques qui a contracté la
majorité municipale plus le problème de
la taxe d'habitation ou monsieur larcher
majorité parle en pourcentage dans tôt
mais les contribuables de rambouillet il
paye d euros et en euros
nota des habitations et 48 % plus cher
que la moyenne nationale donc voilà donc
tous voyez si vous êtes élu vous
réduisez ses impôts s'est passé le
restant des enfants
j'y reviendrai mais je finis sur le site
avait eu du contrôle citoyen on n'a
peut-être pas eu dès le départ de ce
type de situation assez scandaleuse
notamment pour le sictom de rambouillet
donc nous nous allons proposer une
transparence nous ont pas proposé nous
allons nous engager à des mesures de
transparence totale vis-à-vis des
citoyens pour qu'ils puissent contrôler
ce qu'il souhaite la gestion de leurs
élus et nous allons nous allons même
leur apprendre à contrôler la gestion de
leur est dû afin que tout ce sont ces
dérives ne se reproduise pas ils ont
contrôlé la gestion lesquels gestion
vous mettriez en place dans cette
commune quels seraient vos priorités
avec je vous repose la question yat
oubliettes endettement pour la commune
un ferment sens alors cette commune à
l'endettement nous sommes avec ses
emprunts les pénalités d'emprunts
toxiques il faut bien les rembourser
maintenant c'est des pénalités de sortie
il vaut mieux de sortir des emprunts
toxiques que d'en être toujours victime
de cette spéculation avec de l'argent
public sur des monnaies étrangères des
différences de cours des choses qu'on
maîtrise absolument pas il en reste un
peu à dégager ça nous imposer une
gestion rigoureuse à chercher des
économies afin vu la pression fiscale
actuelle qui est du gouvernement fillon
comment gouvernement héros pour
redresser les comptes du pays
de ne pas augmenter les cas en 2014 on
prend l'engagement de ne pas augmenter
les taxes communales d'imposition taxe
d'habitation taxes foncières donc les
vêtements sont être réduites quels sont
les dossiers moins prioritaires nous
avons à l'intervalle nous avons besoin
ça fait 30 ans que c'est la même
majorité municipale
on se demande pourquoi on ne taxe
d'habitation à ce niveau là alors qu' on
n'a pas en arène de plus que d'autres
villes de strates donc on a besoin
absolument d'un audit sur les finances
de la commune dès le départ et sur les
le lot la gestion de l'eau à rambouillet
et de notamment de l'assainissement
parce que là on a vraiment si notre eau
et 63% du shaq la moyenne nationale à
l'heure actuelle c'est surtout dû aux
soucis de l'assainissement qui a été
gérée pendant 6 ans 7 ans par mon
concurrent le dauphin monsieur larcher
marc robert parfaitement qui a été
désigné pour être le successeur de
gérard larcher s'était d'élection ce
sera l'un de vos opposants il devrait y
avoir également une liste pour le front
national mené par philippe chevrier et
peut-être une liste europe écologie les
verts et front de gauche sur cette
commune de rambouillet une toute
dernière question rapidement comment ça
va se dérouler votre campagne à partir
d'aujourd'hui elle a commencé déjà sur
le terrain elle a commencé nous avons
distribué notre déclaration de
candidature il ya une dizaine de jours
dans les douze mille boîtes aux lettres
de rambouillet on a une équipe
suffisamment nombreuses pour le faire on
a de très bonnes réactions des gens qui
nous contactent et qui sont pas
forcément des des gens justement et de
sensibilité de gauche où il restera
jusqu'au centre ça nous rassemblons au
delà de du de notre camp de base si vous
voulez merci jean luc trotignon est
revenu sur ce plateau municipales 2014
qui se poursuit dans quelques minutes
nicolas bauer candidat aux municipales
elle encourt pour le front national sera
sur ce plateau le rassemblement un bleu
marine
face au maire sortant l'ump bernard de
bain gaitan desjardins son ancienne
adjointe est désormais candidate aux
municipales à saint cyr l'école pour
lancer à sa campagne l'élu aujourd'hui
d'opposition ont fait du porte à porte
avec son équipe anthony rech olivier
maniscalco à moins de quatre mois du
premier tour
gaétane desjardins se met en ordre de
marche présente sur la liste de daniel
fargniers en 2008 face au maire sortant
la saint cyrienne se lancent à la course
de la mairie en 2014 pour se faire
connaître des habitants la candidate
sans étiquette politique fait du porte à
porte
de manière générale sont de très bons
échanges enfin moi j'en suis ravi
finalement je n'étais pas rompus à cet
exercice mais j'aime ça je peux le dire
j'aime ça les contacts sont
enrichissants sont francs quelquefois
bien
pimenter ce n'est pas le cas mais les
gens sont vraiment intéressés il ya un
bon échange d'idées gaétane desjardins
fustige le manque d'équipements sportifs
et de structures pouvant accueillir les
personnes âgées l'élu d'opposition
critique également l'absence de cohésion
de l'équipe municipale et la gestion
économique du maire actuel 10 millions
d'euros serait inutilisés c'est pas un
bilan catastrophique
mais ce n'est pas un bilan qui me
convient à partir du moment où les saint
cyriens manque de tout et en plus ils ne
sont pas écoutés enfin d'ailleurs le
maire n'écoute personne comme ça je ne
supporte pas mais quant à savoir les
grandes lignes de son programme les
saint cyriens devront faire preuve de
patience pour l'instant la liste de
gaitan desjardins reste encore ouverte
la campagne a plaisir à présent avec une
alliance entre le ps europe ecologie les
verts le modem et l'association
citoyenne agir pour plaisir les
différentes formations se sont entendus
autour d'une liste commune menée par le
socialiste bernard ansart le prg et
génération écologie soutiennent cette
initiative on retiendra donc que les
militants du mouvement démocrate ont
refusé de se rapprocher de lui des
malgré les choix des formations
respectives au niveau national nous
voyons ici les représentants des
différentes formations locales lors d'un
à presque comme un programme qui sera
dévoilé dans les prochaines semaines
attrape le candidat divers droite othman
dassault a reçu le soutien de l'ancien
ministre du logement souvenirs colas
sarkozy benoist apparu un soutien sur le
terrain et face aux locataires de
plusieurs quartiers de la ville qui
rencontrent des difficultés avec leurs
bailleurs sociaux un échange a eu lieu
pour leur venir en aide c'était en
milieu de semaine dernière nous avons
parlé dans le cadre du 7-8 l'actus sur
cette antenne sur un plan purement
politique nous allons à présent attendre
entendre l'actuel député de la marne
nous expliquer le regard qu'ils portent
sur othman nasro qui mène sa première
campagne municipale
jeune génération qui s'engage des gens
compétents déjà avec une expérience mais
très jeune moi je vois très bien qu'on
est des gens de moins de 30 ans qui
brigue des grosses mairie qui s'engagent
en politique et qui se contente pas de
rester entre guillemets comme on dit les
fesses sur le siège à regarder quelque
chose se passe c'est quelqu'un qui veut
construire tant mieux et benoist apparu
qui apporte également son soutien à
aurore bergé la candidate de l'ump a
mais ni les amours recevra sa visite ce
mardi soir à 20 heures paul blaise
pascal lors d'une réunion publique
autour du logement du cadre de vie et
des transports elle qui a déjà reçu
l'appui de chantal jouanno david
douillet ou encore gérard larcher aurore
bergé et son collectif manie nouvelle
énergie qui par ailleurs dans un récent
communiqué attaque le maire sortant
bertrand aux lions pour la tenue d'une
réunion publique faisant le bilan de sa
politique en matière de sécurité une
réunion qui serait interdite selon les
règles électorales à quatre mois du
scrutin
on part pour locaux à présent et l'on
court où le front national a décidé de
présenter une liste de nicolas barrère
bonsoir vous êtes le chef de file du
rassemblement bleu marine est également
secrétaire du front national de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines où vous
étiez d'ailleurs suppléant lors du
dernier scrutin en 2012 le front
national dans la 11e circonscription
c'était 8% des suffrages exprimés
troisième derrière la candidature de
benoît hamon et de jean michel fourgous
sur la commune plus spécifiquement
d'elancourt celle où vous vous présentez
c'est environ 7% troisième formation
également est ce que c'est ce score qui
a motivé votre candidature puisque c'est
une première une candidature le front
national rassemblement bleu marine sorel
en cours
il ya plusieurs raisons qui ont fait que
je suis candidat il encourt déjà
j'habite à elle en cours depuis une
douzaine d'années je suis implantées sur
le territoire de la 11e circonscription
depuis pratiquement toute mon enfance
toute ma jeunesse et je connais assez
bien ce territoire là moi j'ai adhéré en
2010 au front national parce que j'ai
été attirée comme beaucoup de nos
compatriotes par la personnalité de
marine le pen et je me suis rendu compte
qu'effectivement le front national n'est
absolument pas n'était absolument pas
implanté dans ce coin-là des yvelines et
donc
mon travail ça a été de mailler le
territoire et de faire exister le front
national dans cette circonscription je
me présentais long cours parce que je
suis l encours tôt en 2008 on me disait
n'y avait pas quand le candidat du front
national élection au premier tour pour
l'ump jean michel fourgous qu'est ce qui
a changé depuis 2008 non pas au niveau
national mais peut-être même au niveau
local pour que votre candidature face à
un bon score nous obtienne les 10%
nécessaires pour un second tour par
exemple ça va être l'objectif qu'on va
essayer d'atteindre déjà au minimum de
faire 10% pour être au deuxième tour je
vois moins que le mps est très fortement
ancrée dans la 12e circonscription des
yvelines
monsieur fourgous et l'ancien député
donc il a perdu un cent son siège de
député dernières élections législatives
au profit de benoît hamon sur le terrain
vous sentez que ça a changé quelques
années qu un jeu social sur le tracé
alors depuis que je suis candidat on
multiplie les contacts sur le terrain
j'ai un accueil extrêmement favorable et
des gens qui viennent spontanément
qui nous contactent pour être sur la
liste
on a un très bon accueil au niveau
national dernier sondage en date un
sondage publié lundi par l'union des
étudiants juifs de france réalisée par
l'institut pôle inbox 42% des français
qui n'exclut pas de voter pour une liste
soutenue par le front national aux
élections municipales d'où cette
question que nous sommes allez vous
poser quelle place pour le front
national lors de ces municipales et vous
pourrez réagir juste après
je la vois grandir oui donc parce que
les gens ont peur en augmentation je
pense qu'il va gagner des points on va
dire que c'est une petite appréhension
plutôt qu'une grosse peur parce qu'il ya
aura toujours des gens de bon sens qui
seront là pour dire halte là j'espère
pas bonne parce que j'ai pas envie de
voir ce genre de deux parties prendre
des responsabilités
en france beaucoup de bruit pour rien je
pense le plus loin possible
c'est à dire que
l'on n'a pas on doit dialoguer avec tout
le monde mais je préférais dialoguer
entre démocrates et pas avoir à
dialoguer avec des gens qui nient une
l'humanité
je vous fait réagir à ces propos juste
une remarque on entend beaucoup de gens
dire le front national fera un bon score
va gagner des voix et puis d'un autre
côté on entend aussi mais on espère tout
de même qu'il n'en fera pas donc il ya
quand même des gens qui votent pour le
front national même si tout le monde ne
le dit pas comment vous analysez les
quelques réponses
c'est le jeu démocratique
tout le monde a droit de s'exprimer
d'avoir ses opinions et c'est plutôt de
25 certaines personnes enfin que l'on
fasse pas 100% l'unanimité ce serait
inquiétant
moi même je trouve que c'est
sain que le front national les idées
comporte se fassent entendre dans les
communes françaises on est plusieurs
centaines de candidats qui sont qui vont
s'investir c'est une première d'ailleurs
cette année pour une campagne et unibail
le meilleur second nationale ont dit de
toute façon ce sera quoi qu'il advienne
une victoire puisque actuellement il n'y
a pas plus de cent soixante dix élus
municipaux sur les quelques 520 milles à
travers le pays c'est le secrétaire
général de votre parti qui le dit ça
veut dire tout simplement que
aujourd'hui de toute façon ne serait-ce
que de présenter des candidats que vous
soyez candidat que des listes puissent
se monte déjà une victoire pour le front
national bien sûr c'est une victoire
enfin si
c'est la première fois ça fait ça
participe de la volonté de marine le pen
justement participer
activement à la vie locale c'est dans
cette stratégie d'accès au pouvoir parce
que c'est quand même le but c'est
d'excès de pouvoir et de récupérer les
communes ça veut dire que la priorité ça
va forcément justement ces communes
c'est en tout cas de faire parler du
front national et de se projeter parce
qu'il est les européennes aussi derrière
voire même de penser aux présidentielles
un peu plus tard mais ça c'est le front
national on a toujours on a une vision
on réfléchit pas au lendemain on a une
vraie vision sur le long terme et
effectivement on prépare déjà les
européennes on prépare également les
élections régionales qui vont suivre et
tout ces élections là jusqu'à la
présidentielle où en est votre liste
justement parlez de monter ces listes
ces listes sont bouclés terminé vous
avez tous les candidats dont les listes
alors
on a bon espoir
ça devrait être finalisé dans les jours
voire les semaines qui viennent parce
qu'il faut aussi avoir des gens qui sont
présents table les gens qui sont qui
peuvent nous aider créer une équipe et
des gens présentable
c'est à dire la messe on nous on est si
vous voulez il ya le peuple français
mais il ya un moment faut faire une
équipe de gens sérieux voilà de gens qui
ont quelque chose à apporter
au niveau des compétences de la mairie
voilà et pour l'instant vous les avez
trouvés toutes ces personnes pour monter
votre liste toutes ces peurs là on a
trouvé beaucoup de beaucoup de gens qui
viennent dont la des artisans la des
commerçants on a des ouvriers on a des
chefs d'entreprise des retraités on a
des gens qui viennent du monde
associatif on a des gens qui viennent de
la société civile on a des retraités des
fonctionnaires on a tout ce panel
représentatif du peuple français qui qui
est avec nous les grandes lignes de
votre programme il ya une charte qui
existent au niveau national le chien
candidats mais aussi peut-être des
déclinaisons locales pour la ville
d'elancourt quelles sont vos priorités
vous êtes élu maire quelle est votre
priorité et il y aura effectivement deux
déclinaisons locales il ya des enjeux
locaux mais notre programme on se
tiendra
rigoureusement aux dix points qui sont
sur la charte d'action municipale jean
citer quelques-uns pas de hausse de la
fiscalité pas de subvention projet
communautariste promouvoir un urbanisme
respectueux aussi agir pour la
tranquillité la sécurité sur le terrain
ça se déclinent comment ce programme
agir pour la tranquillité la sécurité
plus de vidéosurveillance les moyens
pour la police municipale qu'elles sont
et c'est exactement ça c'est de donner
plus de moyens à la police municipale et
la police municipale
il faut pas qu'elle soit là juste pour
dresser des pv et apporter de l'argent
aux caisses de la commune elle doit
avoir une action de concertation avec la
police nationale qui a énormément de
problèmes en ce moment et notamment sur
elancourt je peux en témoigner
c'est à dire qu'il ya des manques de
moyens moi je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez il ya eu des émeutes un trappe
mois de juillet nous on était là je suis
allé soutenir le commissariat de trappes
mais également commissariat d'elancourt
qui m'ont fait part des manques de
moyens drastiques qu'ils avaient et dans
le cadre de ces émeutes
le commissariat d'elancourt a été
également attaquée par par des voyous
pour vous aujourd'hui l'insécurité règne
sur cette commune d'hallencourt
la sécurité il y a de la sécurité à
elancourt et je pense que si rien n'est
fait cette insécurité va aller
grandissant moi j'ai des échos aux dons
des gens courtois qui s'inquiètent de
d'incivilité au quotidien d'insécurité
voilà il ya une propagation de cette
violence et je pense qu'il faut
effectivement agir et mettre les moyens
nécessaires pour assurer la tranquillité
des rencontres vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure au début de cet entretien vous
êtes élan courtois c'est pour ça que
vous vous présentez vous êtes tellement
courtois depuis une dizaine d'années 12
ans vont 12 ans est installé sur 7 sur
cette ville quel regard vous portez sur
cette ville sur ce que j'ai fait depuis
douze ans le sur le maire sur le bilan
du maire par exemple j'avoue que j'ai
pendant douze 12 ans j'ai passé mes
journées à regarder la crise actions du
maire moi je travaillais vous vivez dans
cette commune voilà vous avez un
quotidien dans ses mails comme bien sûr
au quotidien mais les gens qui quittent
qui travaillent ils veulent pouvoir les
travaille déjà ils ont la chance d'avoir
un emploi quand ils en moi mais ils
veulent pouvoir aller travailler dans un
de manière sécurisée ils veulent rentrer
le soir par un problème ils veulent
scolariser leurs enfants dans un dans un
cadre
agréable et également sécurisé ils
veulent pouvoir se promener 20 c'est
dans un cadre agréable c'est ça la vie
au quotidien c'est pas regardé justement
le fait mais là on le fait parce que
justement pour reverserait l'encours est
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas possible que la
situation que vous décrivez de vivre
tranquillement dans la ville c'est
possible mais il ya des gens qui pour
eux ce n'est pas possible j'ai des gens
qui veulent partir d'elancourt pour
parce qu'il ya des problèmes de sécurité
la sécurité fait le point principal de
votre programme est-ce que c'est pas le
progrès c'est pas le point principal le
premier point le plus important c'est la
baisse des impôts est d'ailleurs on est
les seuls à proposer les bases là une
baisse d'impôts parce que monsieur jean
michel fourgous est en train de nous
préparer une hausse de 5 points il me
semble qu'il avait dit ça au conseil
municipal
parce que à cause de cette histoire de
rythme c'est possible avec mauss colère
d'ailleurs comme il nous reste assez peu
tant sur les rythmes scolaires quelle
est votre position
cette réforme pour l'appliquer pas là si
cette réforme parce que lui ne souhaite
pas l'appliquer on l'entend duo
nationale plus d'une fois absolument
cette réforme on peut la consulter on
l'a contesté sur le fond maintenant
c'est vrai que c'est une organisation
qui peut être lourde alors on nous parle
d'un million et demi d'euros pour la
commune d'el en cours ça c'est un
chiffre que monsieur fourgous a fourni
je sais pas d'où il sort explique sur le
fond vous la faites vous ne la fait pas
à mais nous on respecte les lois de la
république il ya aucun problème avec ça
une dernière question très rapidement
comment va se passer la suite de votre
campagne la divulgation de la liste le
tractage comment ça va se passer on va y
aura des actions militantes de toute
façon régulière et le calendrier on se
réserve de de le faire et vous
n'hésiterez pas à nous communiquer nous
on remarque bien dans la prochaine
édition de municipales 2014 qui se
referme je vous retrouve dans une
quinzaine de jours sur tv fils le 10
décembre les programmes se poursuivent
bonne soirée